for just a few days removed from what we  assume was Serena Williams farewell  thoughts in the aftermath  you know the first thing I notice is  that the post that she posted after she  posted herself in the bed and said I'm  enjoying my weekend how about you and so  I don't think people understand that  about athletes the first thing I saw was  like she probably finally had like the  best rest of her life in the sense of  not worrying about before she even  retired I remember like last year people  were asking her were you retiring so  there was that lead up to when you start  to get a certain age in sports people  start to retire you like when are you  done like you know you're 30 now what's  up and so I just thought for her I was  like for her to go out the way she did  you can tell that her trajectory there's  more stuff coming but I don't know I  just feel like that's goat status we saw  it